- On this episode I talk about
dress code,
meditation,
and horrible glasses of wine.
Go!
You ask questions, and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody it's Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and welcome to episode 60
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Fun fact about the number 60,
oh yeah, I brought it back,
the number 60 is the number
of D'brickashaw Ferguson,
who is an offensive
lineman the Jets drafted,
oh, I don't know, about ten years ago,
and that was the first
time I showed up on ESPN
pointing to my head that
it was a smart pick,
and I was correct.
Before I get into the
questions this week, or today,
speaking of this week, I know
it's been a little sporadic,
the two week vacation, only one last week
because I've been hustling, went to CES,
had a bunch of meetings, like
yesterday I spoke in Orlando,
I think we do it today, we do it tomorrow,
tomorrow night I go to LA,
so probably none the rest of the week.
Guys, I'm hustling, I'm
trying to put out the show,
I see all of you bantering,
"we want it, we want it."
I know you want it, I'm trying,
but I don't want to put
episodes in the can,
I like the kind of day of stuff going on
because I get to stay in the
pulse of the VaynerNation,
so bear with me, I am running
multiple organizations.
- [Voiceover] Elisha asks,
"the dress-code at Vayner
is clearly casual, do you think dress
affects professionalism or performance?
- That's a really solid question,
the answer is very deep,
the answer is no. I think
that dress does not impact
the performance or professionalism.
I know that some people disagree with me,
I think those people are
going to lose, period.
- [Voiceover] Charles asks,
"is the #AskGaryVee show
"your version of meditation?
"It seems like it helps you
organize your thoughts."
- Charles, this is a really good question,
I saw this one come through the stream,
and it took me a step back,
because I'm like, "does it?"
What I can tell you is this,
I think the brilliance of
the #AskGaryVee Show, when
the business historians
look back at it is (laughs) so awesome,
any way, when people look
back, when I look back,
when the team looks back, when
you, the collective audience,
looks back, when you, the person
that's watching this video
three years from now, looks
at this show and realize,
when I was on it was,
we've created this show
as a foundation point
to all the other content
that I'm putting out,
and so the ability to use
this show that then allows
India and Steve to help me
write Medium forum content,
I mean, I think all of you have seen that
over the last six to eight weeks,
my ability to pump out Medium
and GaryVaynerchuk.com
animated gifs,
all these things all coming
from this central seed,
so the ability to put out this show,
which brings a lot of
value to a lot of people,
it's one great jab at the highest levels,
for people who know what I'm referring to,
and then it's also a
gateway drug to more content
that is content made to be
gateway drugs to awareness
about me and to create leverage.
It's just one big machine of brilliance.
- [Voiceover] Austin asks, "when
someone give you a horrible
"glass of wine, how do you
politely get rid of it?"
- Austin, when somebody gives
me a horrible glass of wine,
I have no version that is
polite in response to such
a negative action. I'm just kidding.
You know, I don't know. My mom crushed it,
I mean, we've talked
a lot about her, like,
it's very easy, it comes very
natural for me to be polite,
I really took a lot of
pride in being the anti-snob
in the wine world,
and for me to be, like, this is crap,
you know, I'm always using the
hedge terminology of, like,
oh thanks, by the way, if you like this,
you should really try this, and
that's kind of my polite way
of saying, this is crap.
You should check this out,
you're gonna like it a hell of a lot more,
and by the way, it doesn't offend me,
and I also, you know, listen,
there is a big part of me that
loves tasting crap wine,
because it gives me context.
It's one of the reasons I
like following so many of you
on social media.
So many of you are putting
out such crap content,
it reminds me what is good content.
And I know that sounded harsh,
and I know a lot of you
are like, "wooo," right.
I know it's a rule to
not diss your audience,
I'm coming to you with straight love,
this is another rant and I'm gonna do this
once every 20 episodes.
You're watching this, you're engaging,
you're all giving me these daps,
you're leaving comments on YouTube,
You're giving me big ups,
and then I'm watching,
and I've had a little bit of
vacation time, when I looked
a little bit. I've had a
little bit of travel time,
where I've looked a little bit more,
I'm getting very deeply
inspired slash connected
to lets say the core 1000
of you that watch this show,
and I've been going down
the rabbit whole and,
I just want to remind all of you,
lack of consistency is
a massive vulnerability.
- Hey Gary, my name is
Michael, I like almonds,
and reading books.
My question for you is, what
can cause the extinction
of the real estate agent, as we know it?
You keep making t-shirts,
and I'll keep buying them.
Oh, and one more thing, ting!
- (laughs)
The bar has been raised
for video questions,
VaynerNation take note,
the bar has been raised.
Amazing question, thank you so much, guys.
Great production. DRock,
you love it, right?
That was good. Staphon,
yea that was good stuff.
I actually don't think
that there is a lot,
you know, I think there
is a false sentiment
in the market that
technology eliminates humans.
I think technology sets up
the humans that understand
how to use that technology
to leverage ahead against
the other humans that don't.
So, what eliminates the real
estate agents of the moment,
in the future? Well, it's
their lack of innovation
and adjusting to the tools
that are at their hands,
and then just becoming a dying breed.
My friends, I'm not making up
or talking about anything new.
Innovation has forever,
the phone, the yellowpages,
radio, television, the
internet, direct mail,
video game marketing.
Every time there's been
another innovation,
and that will happen forever,
it kills off the prior animal
unless the animal is unable to
adjust, and it's not an age thing,
there is tons of 60 year olds right now
that are crushing modern day marketing.
The percentage is very small,
and it comes out of getting fat, right?
It comes out of, you just made
enough money at this point,
you're on to new and better
things, and I mean that.
You guys hear a lot of hustle
from me, but I'm enormously
happy for the gal that's
63, making 240 a year, and,
you know, put in her dues,
and she wants to go to
the fancy food show on
that Tuesday instead of
calling 100 people and
selling another apartment,
or she wants to spend an extra weekend
in an Aspen timeshare. Do your thing.
When I talk about hustle,
please know that I'm not
judging you. It's all
predicated on what you want.
The only people I make
my hustle stuff for,
are the people that are talking shit,
that they want fucking things to happen,
and they want to win,
and they want to buy--,
"I'm gonna buy the Clippers
when you buy the Jets,"
dude, you work four f**king
hours, you ain't buying shit.
And so, that's where I get pissed off.
But if you've decided consciously that
you want to have a great work life balance
and things of that
nature, then that's great,
and those are the people
that get disrupted.
They've lost the hunger
for a better thing,
I'm not looking down at them. Congrats.
Let me tell you a real
freaking secret here on the
#AskGaryVee Show episode 60.
If tomorrow I read that there
was a new drug in the market,
FDA approved, and I could
take it, and it would take--,
this is gonna f**k with
a lot of your heads,
and it could take ambition out of my body,
I would do it.
My gift is my curse.
I love what I do, but I promise you,
and so many of you are about
to be disappointed with me,
but I'm talking truth
here, I would take the pill
that would get me down to ten percent less
ambition and hunger
because I'd have a
little bit more balance,
and there is a lot of attractive
things that come along
with that balance.
But that's not the way it is,
and, honestly, I'm super
pumped the way I have it, so,
and, weirdly, as I'd said that out loud,
I kinda don't wanna take the pill,
but, you get the jist, right?
And so, who gets disrupted? Fat cats.
- [Voiceover] John asks, "you
give with zero expectation
"of return so you're never disappointed.
"That's really tough, how do you do it?"
- John, I do it because
that was the talent
that I was gifted with.
It is the essential
backbone of my success.
And I've said that about other
things, so it's always a mix,
right? Like it's hard to
say this but, like, boy,
boy am I thankful that I have it.
I look for it in others. It is
a huge competitive advantage.
It's like being born beautiful, right?
It's a competitive advantage.
Luckily for me I've got
both (laughs) just kidding.
For me it is really really
really really something
that I'm so thankful for. How do I do it?
Really the same way
everybody does everything,
it was just there.
I didn't cultivate my lack of expectation.
There's no, like, lack
of expectation exercises
that you can get into,
but boy has it been a--
Look, the truth is,
people like people, right?
And people do business with people,
and people sense people through a camera,
through an audio podcast.
They sense people.
I have enormous selfishness
in the things that I wanna achieve.
But the fact that I have
this lack of expecation
and I'm willing to give, and give chances,
and give opportunities,
and just flat out give,
without ever thinking, what
am I gonna get in return,
knowing that eight out
of ten times I won't
get something in return, and it's pure,
it's just the purest version of it,
pshh, I won. And so, like, you know,
I have no clue how to instill that,
but I can do this, why I
answered this question.
I can tell you that if it's
in you, triple down on it.
Don't suppress it.
Don't let the cynics
outside of you tell you,
"no, you're being too nice,
you're not getting anything
in return."
It is enormous human leverage
and I highly, highly,
highly recommend it.
For today's question of the
day, I want to make a statement
of the day, and then I
want you to leave a comment
around it. I did something on
Twitter a couple months ago
and I remember on New Years
Eve I reminded myself of it,
and it made me feel really really good,
and I could be confusing it,
because I do tend to confuse
once in a while,
I don't think we did it
on the #AskGaryVee Show,
but we might of, but
there's a growing audience,
and if I'd done it, one they'll react act
and be, like, "you did it,"
and I'm like, cool, I don't care.
And, two, great, more people will do it.
I am desperate for everybody
who is watching this episode,
whether you're watching it right
now, or two years from now,
to pick up the phone
and call somebody that
they have not talked to
in over one full year,
and bonus points for
somebody that you haven't
talked to in over five years.
I want you to leave the
comment of who you called
and what happened in the outcome of it.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Oh crap, wait. Subscribe!
I need subscriptions because
I can't push this many
right hooks in social. So, subscribe!